[Music]
mike starts us off this hour in
charlotte hey mike how are you
good i'm uh working gonna be on my last
baggy step two debt which is a auto loan
that has zero percent interest
and i'm wondering why i should not well
thank you i'm wondering
why i should not just go ahead and start
saving for baby step three and just pay
that loan out per its terms for the next
10 months
considering mathematically it makes no
difference
well mathematically does make a
difference because we're not talking
just about interest rate we're talking
about cash flow
and also we're talking about you
completely changing your view and your
habits on debt
because the shortest distance between
where you are and wealth is to do away
with and stay away from
debt
and the way you frame the question makes
it sound like you think this is still
smart
like you do it again
no no i would not okay if you wouldn't
do it again then let's get rid of it
okay fair enough it's it's a mindset
shift as much as it is a math equation
personal finance is 80 behavior it's
only 20 head knowledge and so your cash
flow is being eaten up by a freaking car
payment and so what you're doing is
you're permanently drawing a line in the
sand and saying that's it i don't borrow
money anymore
particularly for stupid cars
and um
you know and when you break that cycle
in your head that's when you begin to
move forward on things
it's not just what is the interest rate
uh if interest you know if people were
doing math all the time they wouldn't be
using credit cards if they're doing math
they wouldn't have gotten a student loan
well i think it is a math issue and i
think you've just seen it the wrong way
the reality is whatever that car payment
is let's say it's 350 400 i think the
average car payment's in that range 400
500. it's now 500 my goodness it's gone
up several years ago i did a video for
our company it was like 450. yeah so you
take that number out of that monthly
budget right you're not paying all of a
sudden
it is the math problem in the right way
now all of a sudden we've got some
freedom to put that money as rachel says
freedom to spend it gets that emergency
fund juiced and full up so much faster
and you never know what could happen to
where oh well i've got five more months
and get rid of it now part of the math
equation is cash flow cash cash cash
yeah and and your most powerful wealth
building tool
is your income so eliminate the payment
don't give your income to someone else
even if it's a zero percent yeah don't
do it